seul sur la foule tu perds pas la
bouline soul trop une foule trop seul
tout est cool tu t'écoutes tu te fous de
la foutaise et tout est et tout reste at
on s est ton destin pas le leur c'est
ton festin il est l'heure que tu te
fasses fasse que tu te fasses place
quand on voit que les heures passent se
tasse et aspire dans la masse docile
facile passive et naïve et hâtive active
ont noué rendons le nous fort avec des
jeux forts dont l'âme sort c'est
l'hameçon c'est l'âme soeur de nouveaux
horizons pensons-y quelques heures en
restant seul fait pas ce qu'on dit seul
mon âme bondi seuls les marches gravies
seul un spi grandi ma solitude brandi un
seul jeu resplendit un seul toit caisse
tandis